when one kills he doesn't simply kill
he consumes
he takes everything from his victims
everything they are and everything they
ever will be okay so stranger things
four volume two takes things to the max
with a big ending that sees several
characters dying this includes dr
brenner eddie and max who dies during
the battle with bechner although she's
brought back max is left a little worse
for wear and come the conclusion she's
in an unresponsive coma it's a big
ending and the finale sees max using
herself as bait in order to draw beckner
out so that steve nancy and robin can go
to his body and burn him whilst he's
distracted this works really well with
them getting the drop on him whilst he's
fighting 11 in max unfortunately though
he gets most of the way through his
ritualistic murder and he not only
blinds max but he also breaks several of
her bones killing her in the process
eleven reaches out to her mind and she
manages to revive her but it is possible
that she should have let her sadie sink
into the void
using their good memories she pulls her
back from the brink but she may be
harboring something much worse in wekner
now throughout this video we're gonna be
going through our theories on what's
going on with her how wekner may be
alive and who his next victim is if you
have your own theories then make sure
you leave them below and also don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day without the way thanks for
clicking this now let's get into
stranger things 4.
now the final 50 minutes of volume 2 has
11 not only visiting max in hospital but
she also attempts to reach out to her
through the void we find max in an
unresponsive coma and nurselle tries to
get through to her on the psychic plane
to see if she can pull her back that way
however her mind is completely devoid of
any life or signs that max is there and
this could be because she's technically
brain dead this is also reflected in
what lucas says too do they know when
she awake
no
[Music]
they say she might not
her heart stopped
for over a minute
she died
i i mean clinically then she came back
doctors don't know how
they say it's a miracle
now clinically she died and came back
but her consciousness didn't because of
this she's now an empty vessel and it is
possible that vecna also now exists in
her mind using hers away to continue
living in the season finale he ended up
falling out of the creel house on fire
but when steve and the gang went to
check to see if his body was there he'd
got out of it like nancy did her
relationship when sexy steve smiled at
her
although he was destroyed in this
physical sense will confirms that he's
still out there and we see this
reflected in the environment not only is
the doorway to hell starting to bleed
the upside down into hawkins but there
also exists a black cloud off in the
distance that slightly resembles the
mind player as a child young creel used
to be fascinated with spiders and he
drew the shape that would go on to
terrorize hawkins this was clearly how
he viewed himself as being and upon
going to the upside down he said the
following i saw a means to realize my
potential
to transcend my human form
to become the predator i was always born
to be
so it makes sense that if his physical
body was to be destroyed that he'd then
take on something that looked more like
the mind flayer for his final form
however i don't think that he's this
cloud per se it's more there just as a
warning of what's to come now i believe
that vacuna is licking his wounds and
he's hiding out in max recovering along
with her the series so far has also
hinted at how this is possible at
several points obviously there is of
course will who in season two was
infected with shadow particles and this
created a symbiosis between him and
vechna that he still feels to this day
he didn't fully take over the character
but he was very much a parasite within
him similar to what i believe he's doing
with max there's also the fact that
max's mind was used as a battleground
between him and eleven it's a bit
confusing as to how it all plays out but
basically max goes to the creel house
and then she draws out wekner who from
his hiding place then psychically enters
her mind using a little nina and the
boys eleven is then able to project
herself out there so that the pair can
battle it out in max's brain now having
access to this due to being one of his
victims means that wekner can
technically come and go as he pleases
throughout the first volume he watched
as those he stalked ended up seeing
vivid visions of him before he
eventually launched his final attack
during the time between this he'd
retreat back to his body but if he no
longer had this to go back to he'd
likely have to hide out in max i believe
that he's actually somewhat feeding off
11 though she might be completely
unaware of it in the final few scenes we
see eleven spinning a coca-cola bottle
and in between it we get flashes of her
time at max's bedside when she reached
into her mind coca-cola has been
something that's popped up throughout
the series and at several points this
infamous string has been used to show
11's abilities i think the way that this
editor is carried out and the order of
the scenes could hint towards what's
going on and why beckner is using her
for example we get the coca-cola scene a
quick cut to 11 reaching out to max
hopper's return and then the dark cloud
coming in the way the sequence is set up
makes it seem like it's all connected
and how wekner may end up using 11 as a
way to power himself up due to their
ties for example love is something that
definitely empowers 11 and having hopper
and joyce's return could have added the
slight boost that wekner needed to then
push the upside down out the chill that
will gets on the back of his neck comes
immediately after this and though i
might be reaching i might it does seem
like these moments are played out like
this for a specific reason now max being
lost in the void could also come back
around and potentially she may be the
key to stopping wekner as well bringing
her back from the brink and having the
pair fight it out in her mind for who
gets control over her body would be a
big battle and something that could end
up being the way that the series
progresses i can actually see 11
possibly venturing back into max's mind
and she'll start to explore the darkness
within it until she comes across wekner
who will have maxes as hostage but it's
my mind
not his right
so i should be able to control where i
am i just need to
push him away
the pair might potentially fight it out
there and 11 could end up winning which
would free max and allow her to come
back this might then lead wagner into
going off into another one of his
potential puppets aka will will early on
was introduced as a character who had
massive ties to the upside down and
though max took a lot of focus in the
fourth season when we're talking human
characters that vechna has his sights on
he'd definitely be higher up than her
because he can still feel wekner i think
that he'd be another possible vessel
that he could end up playing into this
is also hindered if we look at the
origins of the name wekner which we of
course know comes from dungeons and
dragons this powerful wizard has several
abilities that also include possession
explaining how he could potentially take
over the future characters now there's
also the fact that we know shadow
particles exist out in russia and he may
end up attempting to get access to them
though murray busts out the flamethrower
to take out some demagogue or gas i
don't believe that the shadow particles
themselves were destroyed and we
lingered on them long enough for me to
believe that they'll be brought back in
some form or another now it's a long
trip for them to fly to hawkins so this
might have just been used as a way to
explain the shadow particles before we
learned that vacuna manipulated them in
order to attack hawkins so this could
have just been a way to hint to the
final reveal before we got it but let me
know below exactly what you think now i
think that the other members of the
group could end up becoming vectors
victims and that once he's back to full
power he'll find a way to hunt the
heroes of hawkins once more who he's
after is anyone's guess but dustin does
fit the profile of one of the people
he'd target through max we discover that
those he goes after tend to have faced
some form of trauma and they harbor
feelings of guilt that make them easy to
manipulate this could be seen in dustin
who could end up feeling guilty over the
fact that eddie died to save him this
was of course also meredith max who felt
like she was personally responsible for
billy's passing dustin could share this
too as that he was getting away but he
turned around to face the bats out of
hell which left him gone when the
morning come
hell who writes this garbage anyway you
get the point with that and i definitely
feel that out of them he's probably the
one who'll be sought after next it
really makes me wonder if they'll
actually kill some of the core cast
members next season as currently seems
like they're playing it slightly safe
when it comes to those they murder sure
eddie was a big death but he and jason
feel like they were created just for
this season so that they could be killed
off now that brenner is dead i also hope
that dr owens comes back as well to
somewhat mentor 11 and take her to the
next level the next the 12.
you suck
now he's also a character that we don't
really know what happened to and it's
unlikely that the military will still
trust him he did however plead with the
army to bring ellen alive and perhaps
after seeing the chopper downed they'll
realize that trying to assassinate it
isn't the best way to go about it not
really connected to the original theory
on this video but i thought i'd just
throw it in there so you get a bit of
extra bang for your buck on the video
and you bloody did didn't you i'm too
bloody good to you but what i'd love to
hear are your thoughts on what's going
on i know there's probably a lot of
different ways that the series could go
so make sure you comment below and let
me know for this one big theory time air
time air time every time we are running
competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once on the 15th of july and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on drop a
comment below with your thoughts and
theories we picked the comments on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
we've got our ending explained linked on
screen right now so definitely head over
there right after this without the way
thanks for sticking through the video
i've been poor and i'll see you next
time take care peace